patrickin die erste Frage vielleicht an
Sie als außenpolitischer Sprecher der
Grünen einmal kurz in die Ukraine wir
kämpfen einen Krieg gegen Russland und
nicht gegeneinander wie fanden sie
diesen Satz der Außenministerin ihre
Partei sie hat damit was zum Ausdruck
gebracht was glaube ich vielen Menschen
im Europa-Rat wo das gefallen ist aus
der Seele sprach wo man sie in Schutz
nehmen muss ist sie hat damit nicht
gesagt wir werden Kriegspartei das hat
sie nicht gesagt aber der Satz hat
natürlich eine katastrophale Wirkung
entfaltet ne
ich glaube sie ist nicht wirklich selber
glücklich über diesen Satz
ich glaube auf der anderen Seite wir
wollen alle dass unsere
VolksvertreterInnen und Volksvertretern
nicht nur in gestanzten Formeln sprechen
zum Ausdruck zu bringen dass sich die
zivilisierte Welt übrigens weit über
Europa hinaus
darin einig ist dass das was Russland in
der Ukraine macht nicht geht nicht
akzeptabel ist dass man damit nicht
durchkommen kann das würde ich auch eine
Außenministerin mal nachsehen
sie ist die Außenministerin es geht um
Diplomatie wissen Sie ja selber viel
besser als ich es geht um jedes einzelne
Wort über sowas denkt man doch nach so
eine Formulierung vorher noch mal ich
glaube sie ist darüber nicht glücklich
aber ich sehe auch und ich glaube die
meisten Menschen haben verstanden was
sie damit gemeint haben es gibt ja
bestimmte Bestandteile dieser
auseinander Umsetzung
die nennt man vielleicht fertig Krieg
das gibt zum Beispiel einen Wirtschafts-
und Handelskrieg zwischen der
Europäischen Union USA Japan Singapur
Neuseeland Australien mit Russland
in dem Sinne diesem Sinne eines
Wirtschaftskrieges sind wir in einer
solchen Auseinandersetzung und wir haben
dabei wenn ich die letzten Zahlen sehe
die wir vorgelegt haben nicht so
schlecht abgeschnitten Putin hat sich
verkalkuliert trotzdem das ist mir
ehrlich gesagt an dem Punkt jetzt auch
ein bisschen zu sophisticated wer macht
gerade die deutsche Außenpolitik das ist
doch die Frage die man sich stellt der
Kanzler hat das sofort kassiert man hat
das Gefühl der arbeiten zwei ums Netz zu
formulieren nicht wirklich miteinander
ich hatte bisher den Eindruck dass die
beiden sich sehr gut ergänzen
[Gelächter]
vorzugeben für die Außenministerin von
Bedeutung ist wir hatten viel zu lange
Außenminister die überhaupt kein eigenes
Profil irgendwie gezeigt haben an dieser
Stelle und ich fand dann auf der anderen
Seite dass der Kanzler mit seiner
Beharrlichkeit auch um den Preis
Media komplett runter geschrieben worden
zu sein hat das ja gegen die gesamten
Mainstream der deutschen veröffentlichen
durchgesetzt dass die Amerikaner sich am
Ende an den Panzerlieferungen beteiligt
haben das fand ich schon eine große
Leistung nicht ablenken noch mal wer
macht er gerade die Außenpolitik ich
habe noch ein anderes Beispiel Katrin
Göring hat auch Ihnen bestens bekannt
wir finden Sie diesen Tweet z.B dass der
der Leopard jetzt endlich frei ist es
ging es da irgendwie um so ein
afrikanisches savannentier ich was ist
das für eine Sprache wir reden über
Krieg wir reden über Menschen nicht
sterben was ist das für ein Sound sehen
Sie ich habe solche Tweets nicht
veröffentlicht wir sind hier in einer
sehr ernsten Situation auch dieses
schwere Gerät ist dazu da andere
Menschen zu töten richtig aber
dass man über solche Dinge nicht so
leichte Sprüche machen genau das ist
glaube ich oder sollte
selbstverständlich sein deswegen hat mir
das nicht gefallen sag ich als jemand
der sich im Bundestag hingestellt hat
gesagt hat das ist leider nötig das zu
tun aber indem ich sage das ist leider
nötig muss ich das ja nicht
verniedlichen was wir dort machen sie
setzen die Ukraine in stand mit diesen
schweren Waffen zu verhindern dass Putin
durchbringt und das ist kein schöner
Aufgabe das nichts leichtes das ist eine
bittere Notwendigkeit
aber die Frage wann sozusagen wird
Sprache dann auch irgendwann gefährlich
und wie eskaliert man auch mit Worten
ich will es mal umgekehrt drehen also
wenn
da jemand ist der die Chefdiplomat in
dieses Landes ist dann könnte man sich
ja auch fragen warum und das fällt mir
tatsächlich in der grundpartei attraktiv
verstärkt auf
massive waffenforderungen Anton
Hofreiter der gelegentlich auch hier
sitzt das sehr klar von Anfang an
eingefordert hat
Annalena baerbock die zwei Tage vor der
Bekanntgabe dieser Leoparden Lieferungen
dem kannst dazu vorkommt und sagt wenn
die Polen das anfragen wir würden uns
dem im Zweifel nicht in den Weg stellen
und ich denke da manchmal wäre ihr Job
nicht eigentlich ein anderer ist der Job
der Außenministerin der Chef Diplomatin
nicht zu sagen das lass uns mal bitte
die große Initiative starten um endlich
mal die Leute an einen Tisch zu kriegen
statt ständig nach neuen Waffen zu rufen
erstens hat sie das einen Tag nach dem
Verteidigungsminister gesagt der schon
gesagt hat das ist diese Waffen gegeben
wird also sie hat dann nichts enthüllt
was nicht schon in der Regierung
verständigt gewesen ist zum zweiten ich
glaube schon dass wir in einer Situation
sind wo wir beides brauchen wir brauchen
auf der einen Seite die Fähigkeit die
Russen in der Ukraine aufzuhalten auf
der anderen Seite klar zu machen dass am
Ende des Tages dieser Krieg nicht mit
einem klassischen Sinne meditärischen
Sieg oder Niederlage beendet wird
sondern durch eine politische
Vereinbarung und dass man dafür sprechen
muss da hat sie aber auch nie daran
Zweifel gelassen dass das das Ende
dieses Krieges sein wird nur zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt stellen wir ja fest
fragen Sie mal Olaf Scholz fragen Sie
mal macron aus den Gesprächen die sie
mit Putin geführt haben fragen Sie
Annalena baerberg aus dem Gesprächen die
sie mit Lafer aufgeführt haben was dann
bisher an Bewegung in diesem Bereich
drin war die Reden anders darüber das
ist mein Punkt die reden das ich glaube
ich glaube das hat das Gefühl da gibt es
einen großen Lizenz sie haben so schön
komplementär oder ergänzend genannt
zwischen Kanzleramt und Außenministerium
und das ist das ist glaube ich das was
das Land gerade nicht braucht ich glaube
dass wir an der Stelle wenn wir das
angucken über die diversen Stadien
dieses rantasten an die Grenze erlebt
haben dass durchaus mit
unterschiedlichen Rollenverständnis hier
sich diesem Problem genährt worden ist
aber am Ende diese Koalition das
gemeinsam entschieden hat die Frage zum
Beispiel wer als Erster gesagt hat dass
wenn die Polen einen Antrag stellen wir
dem nicht nein sagen können das war
wieder Boris Pistorius noch Annalena
Werbung es war Robert der ist schon sehr
sehr sehr weit sozusagen von der
Kompetenz der gestern
nein ihr eigener Parteivorsitzender sagt
auch hier in der Sendung vielleicht doch
wo stehen sie da ich würde sagen wir
haben dann drei Kriterien das erste
teilt diese Regierung mit den drei
Fraktionen sehr Sekretärin ist wie tun
das was nötig ist damit die Ukraine
nicht überrannt wird das zweite ist wir
tun das ohne selber zur Kriegspartei zu
werden das dritte ist wir tun es nicht
alleine und wenn ich diese drei
Kriterien da annehme würde ich sagen zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt sehe ich keine
Grundlage dafür Kampfjets die zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt
die drei Kriterien sind nicht erfüllt
kann auch kommen nein das ist ein Satz
wo sind sie da sind sie dabei abgewöhnt
in dieser in dieser Situation
spekulative Diskussion in die Zukunft zu
führen von diesem einfach geht darum ob
sie fragen persönliche Überzeugung haben
von diesen drei Kriterien sind zwei
nicht erfüllt Punkt okay wenn das dritte
erfüllt ist sagen sie ja
nein wenn zwei nicht erfüllt sind kann
man nicht ja sagen
das heißt wenn das dritte erfüllt wäre
würden sie trotzdem zustimmen wenn sie
sagen ja nein wenn ich zwei habe die
dagegen sprechen dann können wir das
dritte nichts
wenn alle drei erfüllt werden ja
zurzeit ist das nicht so sie versuchen
etwas zu konzentrieren besser versuchen
ist ich versuche nur zu verstehen was
sozusagen im Inneren dieser Regierung
vor sich geht
an genau wir haben immer wieder rote
Linien gemacht und gesagt wenn der der
Leo auf gar keinen Fall deswegen haben
wir eine Verantwortung den Menschen zu
erklären die Übung zur Hälfte der
Auffassung sind wir dann zu viel und die
andere Hälfte gesagt wir tun eher zu
wenig okay in dieser schwierigen
Situation hat die Regierung klar zu
machen was die Kriterien sind an denen
sie ihre Entscheidung ausrichtet und ich
habe ihn diese drei genannt okay die
keine sollen nicht überrannt werden wir
werden selber nicht zur Kriegspartei und
wir tun nichts alleine und von diesen
drei Kriterien sind in dem Fall von
ihnen aufgeworfen Kampf der zwei nicht
erf das heißt man kann sie nicht liefern
schau grad zu ihnen frag mich was ihnen
gerade durch den Kopf geht ich fragte
mich gerade wann man aus chinesischer
Perspektive denn zur Kriegspartei werden
würde wie weit das gehen muss wo unsere
rote Linie da eigentlich wäre was die
Beteiligung Chinas an diesen Konflikt
angeht was ob es reicht dass man die
russische Wirtschaft stabilisiert dass
man Halbleiter liefert die wir alle
nicht mehr liefern machen das passiert
ich meine Worte haben sich verdoppelt
aus China an Russland da wird eine Lücke
reingestochen die wir da hinterlassen
die Hand 40% zugenommen zwischen den
beiden Staaten gibt Autofabriken der
Chinesen die jetzt in Russland aufgebaut
werden also da finde ich eine
langfristige Stabilisierung statt und
ich fragte mich nur gerade bei der
Diskussion haben wir da eigentlich eine
gute Linie was das angeht ab wann müssen
wir denn eigentlich selber Sanktionen
aussprechen die Amerikaner sitzen zum
ersten Mal gemacht haben ein Unternehmen
das ähm
Satelliten Technologie herstellt
sanktioniert weil damit Aufklärung
für Wagner Truppen
wurde satellitenkartenmaterial also wie
weit geht das eigentlich wann fängt
dabei uns eine rote Linie an ich glaube
das ist auch noch so ein Bereich und
über uns wirklich rantasten müssen der
für uns ganz ganz kompliziert wird aber
dann lasst uns doch lass uns doch dabei
bleiben sie mir doch direkt beim Thema
Werte geleitet der Außenpolitik ich habe
das gerade erwähnt der Käser sie haben
im Wahlkampf interessant sich sehr
deutlich für die Kanzlerkandidatin
baerbock ausgesprochen was halten Sie
von dieser Idee sozusagen Werte geleitet
der Außenpolitik zu machen also zunächst
mal zu gucken wie passen die eigentlich
zu uns auf welchem Wert der Fundament
passiert das eigentlich alles
oder umgekehrt sehr pragmatisch daran zu
gehen jemand wie Olaf Scholz da wo es
übrigens auch noch mal sehr deutlich
Scholz auf Besuch in Peking und quasi
die Gegenveranstaltung der
Außenministerin in Münster dem dann von
Münster aus noch den Ratschlag gegeben
hat er möge dort doch mal bitte die
Menschenrechte und die Situation der
Uiguren ansprechen also so viel zum
Thema wir ergänzen uns da gut auf
welcher Seite stehen sie da müssen wir
am Ende weil wir gar keine andere Wahl
mehr haben und in der Falle sitzen sagen
im deutschen Wohlstand zu erhalten
müssen wir wohl oder wehe Geschäft mit
den Chinesen machen oder sollten wir das
auch dringend überdenken ich verstehe
jetzt nicht so viel von Politik aber im
Unternehmen
ist es so dass natürlich immer abzulegen
ist zwischen Werten und den testen
schlagen und wenn ich sehr prominente
Menschen in der Politik die auch
Geschichte geschrieben haben Henry
Christian z.B richtig interpretiere
dann ist ja auch jemand der sagt im
Wesentlichen kommt es weniger
Freundschaften als auf gemeinsamen
interessens lagen an insofern denke ich
werde eine eine interessens
geleitete
interessensgebundene und wertegeleite
aus dem Politik ist richtig und trotzdem
noch mal fahren an dem Punkt kam mir
vorstellen dass ich hier Lieblingsthema
aber sie waren zwei 14 direkt nach der
Annexion der Krim ja haben sie Putin
getroffen unter anderem das erste Mal
sitzende 2020 das letzte mal dazwischen
öfter in sogenannt worden und waren als
in Einzelgesprächen und es kam mir vor
als für dich
sag mal drei Putins gesehen haben über
diese über dieses sieben Jahre Weinen
der am Anfang die Hand ausgestreckt hat
nach Europa versucht hat sich auch
einzubringen sie sind drei Handelszone
2014 oder 2014 vorher nicht nur 2014
dann 2014 15 16 als seine
Wirtschaftspolitik im Grunde gescheitert
war und die Frage des macht der Hals sie
stellte gegen das Thema los aus dem
politischer impact damit man
innerpultisch beruhigen kann dieses
Muster kennt man ja auch von
Staaten von außen sozusagen
das war dann eigentlich schon ein
Problem und ich hätte da ehrlich gesagt
auch die hinfahren sollte das Wassers
unterschätzt das war ein Fehler sagen
sie das war das war insofern Fehler als
zum gleichen Tage die Bundeskanzlerin
mit den damaligen amerikanischen
Präsidenten Obama und andere
glaube ich noch ein bisschen getroffen
hat und über seinen Sonnen beschlossen
das hat die die Bundeskanzler natürlich
Ihre Termine nicht mit mir abgestimmt
aber das war eine sehr unglücklicher
sieht man nicht gut aus ne halt
unglücklicher ja ja ja Zusammenfall von
Dingen das ist vollkommen klar und der
hat das natürlich auch genutzt und das
entsprechend der medial auch
darzustellen gar keine Frage nur 2020
hatte ihn das letzte Mal getroffen auch
wieder unter vier Augen in Sotschi
damals dass man muss im Februar gewesen
sein also kurz vor Ausbruch jetzt
um die Lokalisierung von Turbinen
Know-how in Russland weil er es nach
seinen eigenen sächsischen Worten er
spricht er dann Deutsch sagt er hätte es
satt mit diesem Westen weiter zu
kooperieren und so weiter und so
weiterhin Präsidenten erlebt er in einer
Stunde etwa
50 Minuten mindestens darüber gesprochen
hat was in der Vergangenheit war und wie
schlecht in der Westen behandelt und da
war mir damals klar das Thema geht nicht
gut aus und den Rest aber das haben sie
denn geantwortet
dass ich eine Lokalisierung nicht
verantworten kann
es gab ja auch diesen unglücklichen
Zwischenfall dass er zwei Siemens
Turbinen auf die Krim
exportiert worden das war nicht unsere
Absicht oder Idee sondern aus einem
Bestand heraus gegen das dorthin ich
sagte wissen Sie Herr Präsident
wir haben mit der Krim ein riesen Thema
seiner Zeit gehabt und wir haben es dich
hingeschickt und dann meinte er hatte
sondern russische Turbinen das geht doch
niemanden etwas an was Russland mit
seinem turbinenwarten Sie Herr Präsident
wenn es zusätzliche Turbinen sind dann
schicken wir doch einen Bus voller
westlicher Journalisten auch die Krim
und wir werden ja sehen wir wo die
Kabinen sind und da merke ich dann schon
dass die Gesichtszüge etwas kühler
werden und dann war das Gespräch auch
beendet und sagte dann nehmen sie eben
nicht mehr teil aber Ausbau der
russischen Energie